in the Middle East in what we call the
Golden Age of Islam al-hazin
occasionally referred to as Al hayesan
one of the great scientists of the era
he looked at a cow eyeball saw a lens
saw that you can make an image on the
back of the eyeball and he deduced that
the active site is one hundred percent
passive all reception so you can't just
give someone the google eyes and have
them say oh I feel someone's looking at
me people will still say that but all
experiments show that no you cannot tell
if you do it in a controlled setting
unless you're in the Subway because
sometimes in the subway and you just get
that feeling it comes up the back of
your neck and you turn and there is some
creepy person staring at you and they
don't turn away